among women the most fantasized  superhero is batman among gay men the  most fantasized superhero are captain  america and superman and i found that  difference to be interesting right  because like superman and captain  america are like these goody two-shoes  boy scouts like you know these are the  the guys that little boys look up to as  like the pure and noble superheroes and  i think batman is often seen as like  this sort of darker edgier almost like  he's a villain but he still does the  right thing but you could imagine him  going to the dark side and this is the  guy that women of all the superheroes  that's the one that they seem to like  the most that's so funny i never liked  captain america